you even take Julia to be your lawful
wedded wife if someone's trying to pull
an inception on Ethan Hunt then they
pick the absolute wrong guy by the
minister raised her identity
fools her into hiding Wow and it was all
a dream cliche to open the film you
should just kill me
since when do movie characters nightmare
dream the movie's actual plot I mean
that evil dude does come back and is
behind a nuke plot so can eton
subconscious see the future or what oh
thank god somebody finally heard us I'm
gonna take a sin off for this movie
giving us a city only location text and
not assuming I need to be told Belfast
as in Ireland faint whispers to the war
air a storm is coming
holy a storm is coming even in the
middle of a series of passphrases is
still a goddamn storm is coming cliche
Jesus well they didn't use a rare
edition just so they could get a message
to either couldn't they abuse the art of
the deal instead now all because of Gary
all IMF agents need to verify their
identities by pricking their finger into
a DNA reader and Gary this entire
message is for Ethan Hunt alone and yet
the IMF had to employ at least a dozen
people to even make this detailed
digital presentation with maps an HD
video and my point is at what point does
it become cheaper or easier and less
dangerous to just brief this
motherfucker in person and skip all the
theatrics that are almost certainly only
for the benefit of the viewing audience
anyway don't only by the codename Shawn
Blanc aka John because this message will
self-destruct in 5 seconds but what if I
want to rewind if I miss something that
was a lot of information packed into 2
minutes what a small box beeping he's
late
for Christ's sake get these assholes be
on time for once you know because being
late rarely ever matters one whit in
movie world it's entirely possible to be
relaxed and extremely uneasy at the same
time Ethan was told that a person by the
codename of John lark had hired the
apostles who were in contact with
elements of the Eastern European
underworld that stole the plutonium so
how did they get this meeting set up
with so little information
I know Ethan is a living breathing
rolodex with the names of bad guys and
their associates in his head and could
get some promising lead to set up such a
meet but this is ridiculous
especially since John Locke was already
in contact with them and should have
already bought the goods no lie two
weeks after filming this movie the
plutonium testing app was removed from
the iTunes Store under mysterious
circumstances don't think or tease them
not for me whenever a movie character
tells another one not to do a thing
usually is a noble attempt at sacrifice
99% of the time the
character still does that thing they
were warned not to do by they would be
sacrificer and it's kind of annoying
Ethan not sometimes still has to get his
news from Wolf Blitzer which is sinful
as but the movies going to use wolf as a
mask body double so this is actually
checkoff split sir which was
coincidentally also the name of my high
school Rammstein cover bear well if he
reads largest manifesto basco we're
gonna find out in a minute that Benji is
posing as Wolf Blitzer to read literal
fake news so that this Nils guy will
give them the passcode to a cell phone
I'm just wondering how the can these
guys not get into a cell phone given the
technology we've routinely seen the IMF
use how hard is that to hack the car
accident you win that was an hour ago I
was driving the other car didn't the
self-destruct message tell Ethan that
Nils had disappeared and that John lark
was responsible if he could find him but
I couldn't IMF find him look I can
connect the dots Ethan called somebody
who knew somebody who goes out drinking
with Nils and they found him that way
just don't tell me IMF couldn't figure
this out on their own why do all the
Mission Impossible movies insist on
spoiling themselves during the opening
credits I can objectively say this is
the worst thing about the Mission
Impossible movies well besides the
entire second movie this woman I'm on
amid stop the missile honorable stop us
that sounds like a Bond name that forgot
to include any sexual innuendo also
that's Lady Gaga boom done solved it for
you let's go get a taco because coming
over here from the CIA was the lateral
move some say I stepped down but I did
it because of you no one will be seated
during the strange platonic love
declaration outside the military plane
scene I have operational authority here
direct from the president your problem
with that you take it up with him I have
already and he agrees with me my man
goes then why not just leave with that
the first place no one comes between you
and that plutonium not hunt not his team
not anymore
I love angela bassett but this seems to
be her role in almost every movie come
in say something Turks then leave the
picture until she's needed to get
questioned why can't she go on this
mission I like Henry Cavill and all but
I want to see Angela Bassett kick some
ass assume his identity make contact
with the widow she takes us to the
package the plan in these movies is
always the same just like every other
time his stated plan here will go awry
and they'll have to improvise somebody
should make software that acts as a
Mission Impossible screenplay starter
kit I know you don't want now this
this is the mustache that
single-handedly ruined Justice League
you know why we don't have a living
witness who can identify John Mark or
the apostles it's almost like it should
be super obvious that he is John lor
there's nothing to it is too big right
one of these pink suits they put all
this on in two minutes off movie you're
awesome but you yada yada so much
god damn it Christopher McQuarrie this
is the right here I'm removing three
sins for this camera and stunt work all
of you are madmen all of you I guess you
can pull your parachute aamir a couple
thousand feet above the ground and have
your chute grab onto the spire of a
building and that will prevent you from
dying or getting major whiplash or
injuries not to mention the fact that
the spire would rip a hole in the chute
and Ethan would keep falling to his
death I don't have proof that this
wouldn't work but I have my god damn it
August wasn't just passed out on the
halo jump lightning struck super close
and maybe hit for some apartment he
remained unconscious through the entire
drop but now he's light as a feather and
right his brain I know he's a super
agent and he ain't an alien from Krypton
raves this bitch also raves
this bathroom is a lie Lois in bathroom
it's first of all ginormous and if
you've ever been to a club or a rave you
know the bathrooms are always basically
the size of a bathroom and an Applebee's
if you're lucky second of all how clean
is this people bar bathrooms are gross
dirt pee should be everywhere in this
bitch you got it looking like someone's
about to serve sushi in here that
Stanley Kubrick's goes clean this
bathroom and have expecting Vincent
D'Onofrio to show up and tell us he's
living in a world heathenism an aware of
every single detail going on in a room
at any given time the fact that he
missed this blocking asshole is some
boat these guys walk in giving the movie
a little bit of realism cred as Ethan
and Superman and tried a copy larcs face
but they're the only guys to walk in
during this entire scene remember there
were about ten people in here when Ethan
first came in and this is a huge party
there would be non-stop urination going
on non-stop
he had a date with the widow you look
nothing like him
now we have to hope they never met how
many Mission Impossible movies rely on
the bad guy not ever meeting the person
they're doing business with like all of
them at least half right hope is not a
strategy
said my college girlfriend after I
inhaled the oysters in absinthe
how does McCrory make a human Henry
Cavill character look tougher and more
badass than a Superman cavil character
ever has I'm gonna add another sin for
Justice League because sometimes good
movies need to make sacrifices for the
bad ones we've had a great deal of money
for this information
looks like the White Widow had to change
into a Prison Break planning kotor for
this meeting what happens after the
diversion you want to plutonium this is
the price this is an extremely odd
trade-off it's not like john lark being
impersonated by ethan here needed to do
anything he didn't set up this prison
break he's just along for the ride the
people they have are more than enough to
pull this off kind of surprised ethan
doesn't ask why do you even need me or
at least ask himself what he's really
offering in this deal which is
practically nothing it's Mission
Impossible ride-along
I wanted Logue to lead us to the
plutonium and the apostles wait so the
CIA orchestrated this whole Prison Break
scheme just so they could get to lark
why does this have to be a prison break
at all why does this even have to be a
prison break for a man like Solomon Lane
if the broker aka or the White Widow is
working for you why can't you just set
up a standard bad guys meet in a
warehouse sale and follow him from there
how many times as hunts government
betrayed him disavowed him cast him
aside pretty much once promoted so six
five I guess until it happens later in
this movie which will make it six he's
handing her the phone he says they
pulled off the dead body in the bathroom
suggesting it will have proof that Ethan
Hunt is the real John lark but you guys
are saying lark as a master spawn the
puppet master of other master spies he's
always been way ahead of you you don't
even know what his face looks like but
you think he hired this other dude to be
a lark decoy and that that other guy
used his pink cell phone for that
conversation this is a world where
important messages self-destruct god
damn it man skinny liam neeson doesn't
look so tough in that straitjacket and
leg irons and being so skinny if you
look at the word on nishan in the
dictionary it's a picture of Bilson
look I'm not saying you stop but if
you're transporting the most notorious
criminal in the world in a convoy and a
double trailer truck crashes in your
main routes path right as you show up
there that is an attack you are under
attack do not simply change routes and
carry on this scene goes for the Dark
Knight as well I mean Jesus this little
strip of drivable waterfront road is
literally named Ambush Alley on Google
Maps
luckily for Athens intervention plan the
doors of this van open up after a couple
collisions and dump every single bad guy
onto the street for the cops to come by
and arrest them
whoa Tom Cruise on a motorcycle cliche
and vehicle won't start cliche and one
considering the narrow tunnel he's stuck
in I'm gonna call this clean ship ssin
all three of these assholes myths and
they've got the high van
this movie is just giving all the
fingers to the Bourne movies and I'm
okay with it
yes Ethan is driving against the grain
of infamous Arc de Triomphe traffic but
the sin is this roundabout this is like
the city planner said God will show the
drivers the way and they built it based
on that cops around Ethan a block from
the arc taking up every street except
this one the one he needed all along way
to go French cops okay he called for
special extraction but no way he or they
could have known he'd end up here and
yet everyone did he got knocked off his
motorcycle in a crash that should have
killed it but movie makes it seem like
that was on purpose so he could
disappear right here in the spot Mission
Impossible the French Connection
and it's kind of amazing Paris is on
lockdown after the daring attempt to
break Solomon Lane from his prison
transport Paris needs to hire a Tommy
Lee Jones it's almost like they forgot
about the escape the only thing
impossible in these movies is shooting
the tires I guess I mean she's aiming
for Solomon Lane but her perfect kill
shot didn't go through the glass earlier
so why take the chance here make sure
they can't drive first then kill him
running over your girlfriend priceless
The Syndicate was a pack of murdering
cowards each civilizations last home so
the League of Shadows it's complicated
roll credits wait wrong eyeball the
movie is yours that's amazing
not before what you need attempt to
break clean out because you have to kill
Lane the CIA wanted luck to break Lane
out because they wanted lark to lead
them to the Apostles in plutonium Ilsa
wanted lark to break laying out because
she wanted to kill Lane considering the
sheer amount of omniscience also
displays in this movie knowing about the
Prison Break is not an issue what is an
issue is considering the sheer amount of
omniscience she and mi6 couldn't come up
with a better plan to kill link he's
making you do this
mi6 yes of course mi6 is making her do
this that's the name of the movie right
when the Apostles realize that you're
playing games you'll lose the plutonium
again that's literally a Bible verse I
think it's John lark 3:16
maybe I'm too easily impressed but damn
this is a great movie moment August has
been looking at this monitor the whole
time so how does he end up getting
fooled
there's no double mask thing going on
where Solomon's been Benji and Benji's
been solemn in the whole time and then
they put on another mask of their real
face so they did literal magic here to
fool August in the scene and the movie
never quite explains how it happens is
there any reason why they didn't just
lock August in this cell for a moment
while they cleared things up I thought
we
we did and now we don't movie has
entirely too many double-crosses twists
and turns john lark a fake name
August Walker who works for the CIA and
is John mark Solomon Lane the Apostles
the CIA the IMF the White Widow who is a
broker between the bad guys but who is
also working for the CIA fan who has a
criminal brother with Marvel villains
named Ilsa Faust and her motives to
different organizations wanted lain on a
prison for different reasons the Eastern
Europeans who stole the plutonium in the
first place it is a lot to take in on
top of the double-cross confusion now we
have an action scene that is shot in the
dark only lift my flashlights on well
it's not hyper edited or shot with an
unhealthy dose of shaky cam it can be
hard to tell where everyone is who's
shooting and why we care sorry Alec desk
boss IMF guy doesn't last two seconds
against CIA covert assassin guy more
insane camera and stunt work you know
what give this movie another five sends
off sorry I didn't 2d good luck that's
hilarious but this is their tech guy
he's carrying around a picture of Hunt's
former wife just in case hunt catches up
to him right here and now and she would
wonder who was watching the world well
Ethan's watching me deep down they both
knew that something truly terrible was
going to happen all because they were
together looking Huber's on those two
though Ethan's a fantastic spy but he's
not Batman he's not stopping all the bad
things in the world while spying only
some of them because he's one man Christ
so many better ways to explain their
parting of ways if there's a way to
defuse these bombs I can't find it
you'll figure that I know you are only
in movies do people say like this and
especially only in movies does it turn
out to be true I think I found him
Christ that was fast
what's his last position about 30 miles
northeast and that's where he wants us
to go Solomon Lane has a reaching murder
boner with the manifesto tagline the
greater the suffering the greater the
peace yet his revenge boner is much more
important allowing Ethan to know where
the attack is going to take place even
if it is 99% unlikely Ethan and his team
can find the bombs and fuse them isn't
the fact that he failed to stop them and
let his ex-wife is going to die enough
well Rick just forgot this clear our
only chance to safely defuse both bombs
is to let the
I'm stopped it also would be pretty
being awesome at cinema sets ah sudden
what's Bentley my stop the Jeep all the
way back here is just so Tom Cruise can
run some more come on Ani regain control
of a spiraling chopper and caught back
up to Walker that quickly bummer
the radios are going out I guess because
mountains question if the radios don't
work through the mountains at this range
how will the detonator Walker is holding
work it's also using a radio signal yes
Rebecca Ferguson chasing someone down at
a cabin this reminds me way too much of
the snow man oh god he tied her up all
because he wants her to witness this or
something I really want to like Solomon
Lane but his need for people to know he
got his revenge is making it very
difficult and like this is a situation a
trained government agent can't get out
of Jesus
she clearly says Benji stop and he
clearly heard her and I do think he
should have reacted better but I'm
sitting the fact that she didn't just
yell lans year or ambush or something
more helpful than Benji stop there's
absolutely no reason that this
helicopter should stop tumbling but the
bare minimum of rock apparently stops it
to a halt six minutes left from a 15
minute timer six minutes Eaton started
running after the helicopter 14 minutes
ago
the original script for the sin video
had 15 he survives the sins in a row
here during the film's climax this bad
guy cliche is so disappointing and a
great action movie and considering
adding multiple sins but I can't be mad
at you Mission Impossible 6 I just can't
still once it Christ does gravity
stopped working at the edges of
mountains when moving through Kashmir I
think that's the way to Led Zeppelin
song goes I asked a mathematician friend
calculate the odds that hunt could one
tug that cable and half the heavy hook
end up smacking Walker and that
mathematician who's no longer my friend
he's got 16 seconds folks
16 seconds to free solo the rest of this
mountain and pull the firing key I know
that the movie wants to make it
suspenseful but I'd rather see him
actually do it then cut away and pretend
like he's not gonna do it I know he's
exhausted and almost died like a dozen
times in the last 10 minutes but don't
lie so close to the edge you idiot she
got here not long after you left right
in front of half the Indian army and
she's gone
no minimum security prison is no picnic
the trick is kick someone's ass the
first day or become someone's bitch
football practice
you have an immaculate record some
people don't trust a guy with an
immaculate record I do I have it in back
in the Beckett
the fact that it recorded static isn't
what interests me what interests me is
that it recorded approximately 18 hours
of it fate whispers to the warrior honey
you've got a big storm coming I'm gonna
count to three three shall be the number
thou shalt count and the number of the
counting shall be three is a true Lane
gasps the village of 2,000 people I did
warn you not to trust me
in here when I get three wired guy